J'arrive au mauvais moment au contraire tu as
peur de ne pas venir du tout c'est
quoi le problème les chapeliers le problème
ou le problème du chapelier
le premier non le second Tweedles
c'est le chapelier fou hmm oui je sais
c'est sa grandeur c'est ce qui fait
lui donc lui mais il est devenu plus sombre de peur
qu'après s'être refusé de rire
hmm et aucun de nos plans ne peut susciter une sorte
de sourire nous espérions plutôt que vous pourriez
nous aider à le sauver
pater maman c'est encore toi
uhuhu bien alors longtemps j'en ai toujours
un à chaque nouvelle oui oh  non je veux dire pas encore
drôle j'ai l'impression que je devrais te savoir bien
cap une fois quand j'étais plus jeune
eh bien je dois lire je ne me souviens pas c'est
parce que ce n'est pas encore arrivé mm-hmm
quand cela arrivera-t-il oui à partir de maintenant quand
tu '  je suis plus vieux je te rencontrerai quand tu seras
plus jeune et je serai plus vieux je me rends compte que ça
n'a pas beaucoup de sens son
sens parfait pour moi
je suis terren je sais je suis Alice Aled tu
sembles avoir le temps tout mélangé